okay we are alive we're doing another
coaching session with Jen who is the
fantasy copywriter she's in a new
location where are you jack yeah I met
one of my favorite coffee shops uh it's
just it's just coffee shops it's called
real Aussie it's awesome listen it's got
like a little couch which is nice second
be comfy it looks very professional yeah
it's awesome look you've got the hair
done and the colors the brown with the
brown background it just it looks very
professional I mean it looks like you're
ready to shoot a commercial for
starbucks or something maybe have to do
that next time do one of my videos from
here I love it you should yeah yeah
after this call you can record a video
there you go okay so how are things
going they're going good I really loved
your suggestion of breaking up some of
the elements of a website sales page
into like more detailed so as you
suggested I did one on my philosophy of
call to action and that I did one show
examples of call to action and then I
another one's talking about how to do
that and then I'm working on right one
this week on show like given an example
of redoing one it's artyom on you know
on a website so so yeah it's been great
i don't like i said i was a really kind
of a worry did you know I was wasn't
gonna have enough to talk about but it's
been great I've had plenty to talk about
and it's nice because I can go into more
detail than I would obviously in one
video good and how was the last time we
were talking about the consistency right
consistently going how's that been it's
been pretty good i did get not too long
after our last call I got really really
sick and I like lost my voice for two
weeks so obviously couldn't do videos
then but then once I got healthy again I
started doing it consistently every week
and I feel like I'm on a schedule I'm
doing them I'm filming on Wednesday
nights and I'm working on the ideas like
the sunday before course sundays are
another good day for me to work on it so
um pretty consistently I've filmed on
Wednesday nights and then posted on
either thursday or friday okay so what I
wanted to do was watch a video with you
ok oh no
always it's always nerve-racking seeing
yourself totally um so let me share my
screen right and I want to give you two
some feedback on how to make it that's
great i love it i love to hear your
ideas okay can you see my screen ah
there we go okay which one what do you
want me to which one you want me to
watch um we'll probably the power the
best one I think is the button up your
call to action but you could I mean
either one number one you think you want
a lot I don't have to seen the other one
okay well let's look at this okay so
even even even this evenin looking at
this you can you could switch it so that
the the title is first like the the
fantasy copy is gonna be your theme
right guy right then at the end okay is
especially if it's gonna be a series
when you want to hit people with just
like it's a headline right you want hit
people with the headline see one is for
want to engage with so um yeah okay I
like it yeah okay so let's look at it
and see oh you're on mute sorry we're
good hi I'm Jan and I'm a fantasy
copywriter at you so much calm and I use
fantasy in my copy to tap my peoples
dreams and desires and I've lived the
best way to make your fantasy come true
is to write it down because words make
it real so I'm continuing my video
series about how to write copy for a
website so even all that I would try to
make a little bit tighter okay so let's
watch that again hi I'm Jan and I'm a
fantasy copywriter okay so even careful
though hahahaha I stopping why Evan
thanks okay let's back that up there we
go okay good okay I always I always I
always pause myself on terrible terrible
moments oh my gosh it's so funny that
particular video to I can't possibly
like funniest the funniest faces I've
made during that thing which I'll take
is kind of a good thing because I wasn't
obviously
very animated that's good so so I would
started by being more um practice being
more genuine okay less nervous I'm more
genuine because you you're very I mean
now you're very genuine and very genuine
person in general and that that doesn't
quite come out yet in the video so
listen that even how you talk you
introduce yourself hi I'm janam even
there you've been there haha okay I
totally see your point right so yeah you
know so and it'll come with practice the
cons of practice it's not a and you know
you're worried about what you're gonna
say and the content and making it polish
and but even right now like that start
um a little more just more you it's
already look when the last years I've
watched it's already getting better but
be even more you need more gin ok good
at usum so I wonder there I'm the
fantasy copywriter are you so much com
um I'm one of those a tangent I wonder
if that's switchbacks i can see i wonder
if that gets people gives the wrong
message only that fantasy copy this
fantasy books right right now i right
you lose people on the on that i'm a
fantasy copywriter it's not going to the
first thing they think of so is that you
know intentional or we lose in people
because it's not relevant that's good
question I mean I feel like I I want to
make sure to mention fantasy obviously
right that's part of the movement and
part of making sure the people you know
as you're looking for is a fantasy
copywriter that they found in the right
place but you're right if they're new
they may be confused they may not
understand that women let's just listen
to what else you say to watch calm and i
use for you to see in my copy to talk
with people's dreams and desires
and I've lived the best way to make your
things he come true is to write it down
because words make it real some could so
so we're getting more into the
nitty-gritty of YouTube success is
that's I paused that at 15 seconds okay
the 15-second intro without even talking
about what you know mm-hmm can be long
ah I wonder if there's a way to make
that uh one just more not just shorter
but also more impactful okay I like
using fantasy to tap into people's what
did you say dreams and desires yeah I
dreams and desires I wonder if you could
talk more to your clients yeah like say
hey I use famous need to help you know
show your customers as you make your
fantasies come true or something like
that yeah I i I'm a copywriter that uses
your clients fantasies to help you sell
more or something I don't know right
right all right then it it's clear one
that you're not you're not writing
fantasy fiction right um and and it's
also i see the benefit to me like you're
gonna help me sell more who read that
still mean at the end marathon helps me
sell more right so let's look let me
know okay um and you're still using
fantasy look but but saying it saying a
fantasy copyright i think immediately
will get people uh thinking something
else mm-hmm whereas if you use you can
talk about how you you tap into your
customers fantasies to help help you
sell more products and services or
something like that it could be better
but you're the copper you can figure it
out yeah i'll work on it i like that
idea I like we're going now yeah for
sure yeah so so already this is the
first 15 seconds so more genuine and
then a traitor more more easy to
understand open
okay right let's look back and see you
give me my video series about how to
write copy for a website sales page and
again a website sales page is any kind
of page on a website where you're trying
to sell something so the goal is to get
the reader to continue reading down the
page until they click on that buy button
and that's why use fantasy because let's
face it if you can't tap into someone's
fantasies and make them feel like you
understand what they're really truly
feeling and desire then they're not
going to buy from you so it's super
important to make sure that you
understand their fantasies are and the
things that you really want to make sure
you include on a website sales page are
a headline a customer-focused message
web headlines bullet points slow and a
call to action of course and then
optional extras such as a PS or
guarantees that kind of thing in the
last video I kind of talks a little bit
about my philosophy on call to action
and so if you get a chance i highly
recommend you go back and watch that
video and so today I'm going to talk a
little bit more about called actually so
so we are a minute 13 mm-hmm what we
start talking about call to action right
what this video is about yeah um yeah I
thought about that too wasn't sure if I
should if I should like recap the
elements of a website sales page in
every single video because it does kind
of begin to feel redundant yeah and you
want people watching the series like
you'll get a lot of views coming from
they watch one then they watch another
they watch another they want together
right not that starts to get repetitive
yeah and you also aren't that interested
what are you talking about it you feel
like trying to get through it and and
recap today okay now we can start on the
what this video is all about right um
what some people do that may play well
with this and so it's a young personal
style and see what you experiment and
see if you like it
with my videos now I don't I don't
introduce myself ever anymore right and
I don't say uh I don't I don't explain
um believe much anymore but there's so
many videos that I've made and it's part
of a series and I always end with
believe I got the gear on that you me at
that level yet but what you what you may
want to do is lead with a powerful
opinion on a call to action or today I'm
going to talk about how to have a
kick-ass call to action because you know
if your call to action sucks you're not
going to sell anything or something like
that right like with something related
to the topic mm-hmm and then you can cut
to hi I'm Jay and I write fantasy coffee
to help you or not friendly not very
sick whatever we said before right
ensure that you're working on yep you
have that you have the teaser at the
start then you have your quick intro
into what you do and then so you're
talking about how this is part of a
series okay is part of my series about
how to build a successful sales page ah
and then you go into two things you
recap what a sales page is and then
recap uh well then you recap why
fantasies important to a sales page and
then you recap better part of a sales
page we get to what we're talking about
which is our call to action um yeah it's
okay to say it's part of a series um I'm
wondering if you can tackle it through
um like a playlist give a playlist for
your videos and you call it you know
successful sales pages right um and you
can include the playlist in the
description of the video easiest part of
my series on how to write us how to have
a successful sales page
you can check out the other videos in
the description link below or you can
have an annotation I'm trying to keep it
simple you can make an annotation and
show the video on your screen with you
yeah this extra editing work and I don't
want you to get bogged down and seeing
that there's so much editing that you
don't do anything right right which is a
you know it's a problem yeah um and so
then each time you don't have to recap
what your what your what the seven
things are yeah we could dump jump in
and say okay this is this is number
you're not actually going in ordered all
right the call to action is not at the
top it's at the it's the bottom at well
near the bottom and I actually haven't
been going in order now okay so but um I
like the idea I what about just putting
even in a description like in the
YouTube description like these are the
elements to include in a website sales
page you know today we're talking all
that [ __ ] you know I'm saying yeah um
yeah I like it and then what you could
do is put that into this put that in a
playlist Emily order it um as I guess
you come out with them right and then
put them in the right order so they're
going from one to right so eventually
someone could actually watch them an
order yeah yeah or does it matter like
this you're to matter it's just them is
it just here are the seven things that
you need to know yeah I mean it may not
because you really need to know all of
them in order to write a good sales page
and someone may feel really confident
headlines but they want more tips on
called action or whatever what and then
the series can evolve our okay we've
gone through it we've gone through the
seven points and then maybe show a few
examples maybe that's 10 videos on a
sales page and then you can go to
something else you can go to a retail
environment or you can go to
advertisement or you can go to a radio
script there's something really you can
apply all the same yeah what a different
so example what I'm doing obviously help
entrepreneurs um I'm starting a series
targeting different niches so the first
one I'm doing is
is for fashion entrepreneurs I called
the Commission premier series cool and
going in order of you know finding your
passion finding your first customer all
of that all the stuff I talked about but
then applying it to the fashion business
yeah or you can even break down the
sales letter and and make playlists for
e-commerce and for you know different
you know if you're a coach if you have a
service if you're ready to be hope you
people on to your newsletter and then
you can break that process down so you
have lots of potential options um I'd be
thinking about like where where where do
you like to focus you know where do you
get your customers found where do you
want to be okay reaching with the videos
um it's good idea I guess looking
through that I want to tighten that up I
don't want it to go a minute 13 or
minute 15 whatever it was before I get
the juice about call to action yeah okay
cuz we're also going to get people who
um we're going to be searching for call
to action right all the action and and
they me well they probably won't have
the patience to sit through all of that
right so it's not helping the new people
so much because they want an answer
quickly and it's definitely not helping
the existing people because they've
heard it all before though it's yes
because I think it's close like you have
a lot of the elements they're just
tightening that part up cat the play
with I see what feels right um I'm
thinking helpful exercise to go through
to help make the videos better yeah
that's great you may want to consider
too in your titles this one is called so
fantasy copy button up your call to
action might want to make it a little
more search friendly okay ah because you
know button up your call to action might
be a good magazine headline right but
nobody's searching for that right so you
know if we do a search let me share my
screen again
yeah it's funny that you mentioned that
because I did I did do a search on call
to action and it didn't come out my
other one did and that one didn't and so
I actually changed because I originally
just had a calm button up so i changed
it so probably would be more likely to
come up they'll call to action i just
did a quick you know you can you see my
screen oh yeah again it's called action
okay so star wars in your video pillar
button lyric you got a bunch of stuff
but um you know what's related here call
to action your video that could be you
do a video but how did you call the
action in your video right called but
what we're actually talking about right
right a call to action button um of
action button on Facebook WordPress call
to action button how to add a call back
but these might be kind of more
tutorials technical but call to action
button is going to be much more search
friendly title so how to write a call to
action button know how to make a call to
action button um or how to write a call
to action for your website yes a free
website are for like a sales page yeah
uh-huh oh I would you just do a quick
search here to see can we can also do a
Google search if you see what people are
typing cuz if you call the action
examples call to action phrases pub
Action Button huh that is interesting
and you might get idea excuse me if you
target a video around buck you a key
phrase here then you might show up in
Google like the Google the YouTube
videos will show up in Google results as
well okay right the call to action
examples in writing all the action
phrases business call to action you know
how to write a call to action for your
website or something right leg just
doing a little quick you're doing so
much work and making the video in
preparing for it that quick search do
fine at the title is what you have is
is great it's cheeky like if I'm if I'm
my subscriber already it might make me
want to click on it more but it's not
going to help you in terms of getting
new right especially to this kind of a
call to action button is uh is a term
right but you're not really helping them
do a call to action like it seemed ball
it was seen really technical like how to
do a call to action button and we ran
through facebook right button up like
you're using you're using button not the
way people are searching for it yeah
right let's meet a little more um more
practical how to write a call to action
for our website or first sales pain I
think would would help you drive a lot
more use okay yeah I like that idea okay
so that's that's our that's just our
kind of whoops whoa that's just our kind
of opening intro in title now we're
gonna actually get to the coffee
continue that in this next video so to
quickly review what I talked about my
last video the most important thing
about call to action is that you are
very very clear about what action you
want them to take you also want to make
sure that you address every single
fantasy and objection that they might
have before they get there so they can
make a decision on whether or not they
going to take that action and then the
final thing is you want to make sure
that you know how you want them to feel
and that they stay with your fantasy is
right around the corner when they click
on that bye-bye so today what I'd like
to do is what cement so it's even more
review there right yeah totally i was
reviewing the last video but it's it's
not bad to have liked to have a teaser
to write it could be you know if it if
you need to have that information then
you can tell some of the points but if
you don't like ideally wanted you to be
to be a standalone as part of a dialogue
so it makes me want to thank oh what's
where's the last video how do i find
that last video and then it's in the
description below all the links are so
helps me want to write
I explore your chin a little more deeply
cat ok let's go a little I'm know we're
bumping up against the clock that let me
slip into it yeah that's great oh you a
few websites that I thought did a really
great job with a call to action and the
first one I want to look at today is
fresh pressed olive oil calm and this is
a website that is for olive oil
aficionados so as you can imagine
someone who's a real passionate foodie
who loves olive oil and one of the
things let's take a look here the
website one of the things that I think
is really awesome about this call to
action is that it is so clear on the
button itself what it is you were signed
up for right it says right here click
here to enroll in fresh pressed olive
oil Club there's no question what you're
signing up for your sign up for an olive
oil Club which probably means without
knowing much about it now remain in the
copy what you may what you may want to
do there is just hit me before you show
the example hit me with the theory can
though so this one if it's that it's
clear right so your call to action has
to be really clear so I know what I'm
getting here's an example from fresh
pressed olive oils and I see you know
whatever it's super clear that i'm going
to be getting XYZ from them when i sign
up i pad and you can jump to others
right right well that the first one was
clear the second one is whatever your
second point is it's got to be I don't
know it's gotta be in your face and loud
right right so here's an example of it
in your face and loud one or it's got to
be super personal here's an example of a
personal or those options you can do
this or this or this here are different
ways to do it if you do quick like gin
theory and then the example then um and
with the theory like a little bit more
to it so it's got to be super clear and
then a sentence or two why does it have
to be super clear has to be super clear
because all right and the drive man
right right um not could be its own
video like just on um clarity in call to
action we
long have to be it has to be super clear
because if it's not XYZ people
understand whatever you're you know Jen
theory is and then you show two great
examples and too bad examples and that
could be the whole video and then
something else on the next week you do
another call to action talking about
whatever your next point is having them
a little tighter uh what happens like
it's definitely overall I think you're
getting better you used to I think I
mentioned you when we chatted before
used to always go up every time you have
a point and so now you're it's a lot
more it's a lot more refined um right
it's model sounding yeah well yeah so
now a little so you have that it's
confident like it sounds like you know
what you're talking about just a little
more more natural more not over-the-top
personality just like just like you saw
this and what do you think like oh
really trust this person I understand
what I'm getting from them this just
like you're talking now right and it
like it comes it'll come with it's
already getting better you're you're
progressing faster than than I was so
it's good but just something to be
talking set up so you don't a danger
with making the videos is then you you
dick on a pattern yeah it's hard to
break out of the pattern even though
changing your intro will be hard because
you've set the same enjoy totally I
agree old to be hard for me for sure
yeah how'd that memorized now well not
the other thing too is that they have
become easier because there are some
things that I've memorized but also I I
think I've done a better job of not
scripting everything out I used to
script everything out like every single
word and then it comes off sounding
totally not genuine at all so um so that
yeah but I think I think there's a fine
line between not scripted anything out
and having it a little bit more
organized so that I can be more
sustained yeah yeah oh well um I'm
looking forward to more videos me till
you see a closing in on the thousand
views on the channel so that's exciting
I know getting closer and every week
every week company
when I exactly it may help your thinking
to start going in order I mean play it
by ear do what you feel is right um I
find it helpful that I have my points
and I know how to I'm going from one to
the other um but you know do what you
feel is great okay sounds good thank you
so much heaven yeah well we'll keep me
posted on email and we'll chat soon well
damn thank you thanks Jen hey